a California teenager accused of
impersonating a sheriff's deputy is now
on the wrong side of the law home
surveillance video captured the 14 year
old wearing a law-enforcement uniform
with what appeared to be a real firearm
in this holster police say he drove an
SUV equipped with flashing lights Carter
Evans is at the police station in
Victorville California with what led to
the teenager's arrest Carter good
morning good morning the boy is set to
appear in court later this morning he
was on probation when he was arrested
his family tells us he wants to be a
police officer when he grows up and that
he was obsessed with the show cops even
wearing a uniform around the house he
had all the markings of a law
enforcement official flashy lights and
what appeared to be a San Bernardino
sheriff's uniform but when the 14 year
old said he was responding to a domestic
disturbance call jasmine Jones was
suspicious you kind of knew something
wasn't right he looked like baggy
clothing kind of casual like a security
guard that was just giving a job Jones
told the team there was no problem at
their home and went back inside you can
see the boy tried the door handle before
turning to leave in a hurry
puzzled Jones and her grandmother Sharon
koala called 911 a tease watched the
video when they arrived came initially
we were stating well that's ours that
looks like ours well that looks like
ours but they couldn't tell either so at
first they didn't even know they left
they didn't even do a report but a day
later police arrested the teen after
spotting him in the same unmarked Ford
Explorer he was allegedly driving at his
home investigators recovered the uniform
he'd apparently been wearing and all
kinds of police props there a ballistic
vest a ballistic helmet a Taser
authorities say the stash included fake
guns a police radio even counterfeit
cash all in the home he shares with his
great grandmother his legal guardian a
neighbor who did not want to be
identified told us he'd seen the team
before just walking around the
neighborhood at night wearing uniform
and I thought it was kind of odd kind of
weird this is not some kid just messing
around this is serious business
he was absolutely playing it to its
fullest it wasn't just something that
popped into his head and he acted on it
spontaneously it's something that you
know he really put some thought into
police say the teen had contact with at
least two other people while he was
posing as an officer he even initiated a
traffic stop pulling a woman over he
took her information and then let her go
with a warning police and think he fake
picked up his uniform from a thrift
store
fionna kind enough to let her off with a
warning quite the imagination for this
kid and grace you know what he was on
probation for them now it sounds like he
kneeled a theater school and maybe end
up in Hollywood yes likes to go a
different direction yeah maybe